welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this video
we're breaking down the second episode
of snowpiercer
the series is now airing on Netflix and
for the next nine weeks we're going to
be breaking down everything you need to
know about the brand-new show throughout
this video we'll be going over what
happens in the second entry its Easter
eggs and giving our theories on what's
going on on the train there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet then I
highly recommend that you check out
right now if you enjoy the video then
please consider subscribing and dropping
a thumbs up as it massively helps us out
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
snowpiercer episode 2 okay so the second
episode picks up in the wake of the
revolution from last week we see things
from the perspective of Josie who last
time we learned was in a relationship
with Layton and both were surrogate
parents to a boy named Myles we see
Routh examining the wreckage and she
wants more Don's the coat that Minister
Mason wore in the movie showcasing how
cold it is in the tail end of the car
she brings an announcement from Wilfred
that all uprisings will not be tolerated
and they take a child who was complicit
in the death of six security guards just
as they're about to punish her by
freezing her arm and mother stands up
and asks that it be delivered unto her
instead unto her Amana I felt like I
said that in Times New Roman anyway the
mothers arm is frozen instead and as we
saw in the film this grueling punishment
is carried out by placing someone's arm
on the outside of the train until it
fully freezes and it's then shattered
with a sledgehammer which to reoccurs
here missing arms are often seen on
snowpiercer
as a symbol of those that have dissented
and we've already seen the character he
born from last week bearing this here to
make it even more gruesome they pour
water over our arm to freeze it more in
the prison car the three that Layton
convinced to stand down last week are
sedated with chronal and placed into
drawers this is clearly part of Layton's
plan to place sleeper cells further up
the Train and I love how the person
delivering the sentence says that may
God have mercy on your Spock sparks
being used instead of souls cements the
mechanical and industrial language it
shows that Wilfred views people as part
rather than humans in the movie we learn
he'd been abducting children under five
and enslaving them because they were
small enough to fit into a certain
section in the engine and this spark
replacement definitely hammers home how
the upper-class view those below the
phrase eat the rich is uttered by Josie
and this is a saying that has recently
picked up a lot of attention due to
inequality but it actually comes from
the 17th century where it's attributed
to jean-jacques Rousseau the full phrase
says when the people shall have nothing
more to eat they'll eat the rich this
means that when the upper-class takes so
much for themselves because of greed it
will eventually lead to an uprising by
those that have been left with nothing
after the credits we cut to the engine
room
or rather Kapil's compartment and the
Train is rocked by an avalanche we also
see in her room that she has a picture
of a child man last week it was teased
that she had a daughter she speaks with
the engineers in first and due to the
weather there's a lot of danger that
surrounds them there's also a clue that
cavil isn't actually Wilfred as javi
asks Bennet how long he thinks she can
keep this up he says it's been seven
years already
so clearly she's been masquerading as
well fed for that amount of time we
still don't know what happened to
Wilfred and either he's in holding in
this or it's the first time a TV show
actually killed Sean being off before he
was able to make an appearance anyway we
don't know yeah but this sentence
definitely adds a lot more weight to her
not really being the character at one
point her badge is upside down and the W
looks like an M M is of course for
Melanie and Ruth adjusts this by turning
it back to at W it is possible that even
she could be in on it too and I love the
symbolism of the M changing to a w
perhaps showing that Melanie has changed
into the character she speaks to those
in first class and we see that the
Folgers bodyguard has a gun I'm sure
that people aren't allowed guns on the
train if they're not security but this
may be a gray area with him being
personal security anyway they're not
happy with Melanie and who knows she may
even be overthrown in the same way that
she could have overthrown Wilfred Layton
is kept in a Cell and Beth and rauch
come to visit him Beth and Layton are
forced to work together throughout this
episode even though she still bears the
bruises of him knocking
last week they go to the market cart and
begin interrogating people before the
autopsy of Sean wise because his body
was found Nicky Jay has been taken out
of suspension and we see jin-joo caring
for her we don't quite know what gingy's
role is yet but because she's able to go
further up the Train it does seem like
she's a prominent figure I'm guessing
she's a scientist as this would explain
why she's held in such regard and next
to Melanie she's actually one of the
most mysterious characters in the show
anyway after Layton and Beth find out
very little they venture to the night
car where we see a performance of say it
ain't so Joe this is a real song by
Murray head and the singer said that he
penned it in the memory of fallen heroes
which could exemplify how the train
views the loss of the security forces in
the wake of the Revolution however
another interesting aspect of the song
that head went on to state in 1995 does
resemble a lot of things that we see in
the show in modern society had said
saying so Joe was provoked by a 70s
documentary on Richard Nixon prior to
his resignation the presenter was asking
the editor of a small-town newspaper
outside Washington how in the face of
conclusive evidence and proof his
readers could still show such undying
support for the president they elected
the editor likens the situation to a
scandal in the 20s when Joe Jackson the
famous baseball player was rumored to
have taken a bribe to sink his team in
the final of the World Series his fans
hung around the stadium chanting say it
ain't so Joe
it's use in the show could be a comment
on how people still blindly follow
politicians ignoring their bad sides
which yeah in recent times that let's
not get into it in the fictional world
of the Train it could show that though
many worship Wilfred as a deity some
really see him for what he is a cause of
injustice and inequality however it also
shows the blind devotion of his
followers that have it good and refused
to acknowledge the mistakes that he's
made they interview the singer herself
Audrey and she must be somewhat of a
celebrity on the train because in the
market car we see posters of her hanging
up
sheis courts light into a hypnotic
aquatic room where he's able to meditate
with Zora his ex we see how they met and
that they were engaged at one point but
a girl's got to eat and sometimes you
got to join a chain
so you can run some train that's quickly
becoming a catchphrase of these
breakdowns and yet we peaked at the
bottom after reconnecting they reconnect
and Zara tries to get Layton to stay up
trained but he's obviously torn by josie
and miles being in the tail the autopsy
is carried out and they determined that
the butcher's would have the
capabilities to do this we also hear
cows mooing and see the livestock
firsthand in the film it was said that
animals were thought to be extinct but
there were chicken eggs so who knows if
this was the case either way the cows
are quickly wiped out after an avalanche
starts so this could be the reason that
many thought that they were extinct
we're still unsure whether this show and
the film will connect but that's just
something to bear in mind after things
died down Layton and Beth discover a
body in the freezer which has been used
to serve beef in the market car we also
see that there are suits that allow you
to travel outside of the train and this
means it may be possible for someone to
venture into the wilderness of the world
I don't know if that will happen just
letting you know they have the
capabilities to go beyond the Train if
they need to another interesting aspect
is that we see a brakeman dealing
chronal though this is used as an
anaesthetic the character should not
have access to it so it is possible that
a black-market exists on board the train
and this would explain why in the film
Nang Geun was able to become a chronal
addict in the tale miles has recruited
for an apprenticeship and he separated
from Josie we don't exactly know what
kind of apprenticeship this is for but
miles is obviously very close to Layton
and it could be another person of the
Train that helps him with the revolution
Beth has a massive change of heart - and
we actually see her go on a bit of an
arc in this episode initially she allows
God's to push Layton around but after he
starts to crack the case she defends him
from one perhaps showing that Layton
being brought to the front will slowly
start to change people's minds and those
in third may even join the tale in their
out pricing unless you in first you're
pretty much there to be stepped upon and
whilst third and the tail have been
turned on one another through
manipulation by the front it is possible
that they may unite which Beth
definitely showcases Layton draws a map
of the Train as well leading me to
believe that he is indeed still planning
his revolution he escapes his cell and
leaves it for people in the tail that
have been brought up to work Layton also
allows himself to be used as a punching
bag in order for them
to get the information and it's nice to
see that being upfront hasn't changed
his principles one tale
thumbs up if you like one tale Melanie
obviously isn't happy with this and she
goes to visit Layton in his cell and she
tries to explain the economy that exists
onboard snowpiercer Layton reveals that
he knows Shawn Wise was an informant
that was paid in perks and the only
reason that they were investigating it
is because he may have given up things
about Wilfred when he was tortured so it
does seem that someone onboard the Train
most likely the killer knows that
Melanie is masquerading as Wilfred now I
think Layton was pretty stupid to admit
this because all it does is put him
directly in the firing line I think as
the show goes on he will of course earn
enough that Melanie and Wilfred are one
in the same and this will then lead to
him being taken up by Melanie if she was
willing to kill or at least cage Wilfred
as we've theorized then it's more than
likely she would do the same to Layton
she could merely tell the tale that he
decided to live up train after solving
the murder investigation and then she
could easily tell those up-train that he
decided to return to the tale it would
be the perfect crime and who knows what
she will do as for Wilfred we do know
that Sean Bean is cast as the character
on IMDB at one point in the episode
Melanie takes a long look at the
prisoners in the drawers and it is
possible that she even has the real
Wilfred stored away in them in case she
needs to bring him out I definitely
think that we will be seeing him in some
form or another but exactly how we don't
know yet overall though it was another
cracking episode and I'm so glad we're
getting some great television like this
in the lockdown
snowpiercer has a two solid episode so
far and I'm very excited to see how
things develop going forward and what
other twists and turns were in for
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
and what your theories are on the show
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video and didn't get a
chance to see our breakdown of the first
episode then make sure you check it out
after this you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month and please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to people our
subscribe to the channel and this Manti
can win the marvel face the report to
boxer and all you have to do is comment
on a video
and make sure you sit with notifications
on more video is he comment on the more
you have a chance of winning so make
sure you get involved the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of June
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised so best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you